[Musik]
bbb großes b gesagt ach so ja okay das
ist schade selbst mal herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich bin
heute hier mit luca und wir zocken einen
dingen was ihr bestimmt schon kennen und
zwar youtuber strichmännchen
funktioniert so funktioniert einfach so
perfekt an
ich würde sagen du fängst mich raten ich
mache jetzt aber strichmännchen ihr
kennt ja alle das spiel zumeist keine
strichmännchen ich mal da hab ich mal
wartezeit genau ich mag die strecke für
namen von youtube der hat nämlich für
buchstaben haben und du erlebt sie dann
und wenn es nicht jetzt kriegst du
123456 stadt ich manchen fehler und dann
beschließt also ich danke rechte
projekts fehler machen
1 356 machen und dann beim sex bis zur
ausdrücklich den punkt okay fangen wir
an mit sabrina so kontrolle her
für den perfekten anfangen gebe ich ein
bisschen was leichter das entsprechend
korrekt dass es so einfach wird
wahrscheinlich darf ich sagen cds nicht
wenn die kundschaft da wird genau
gepasst hätte passt ja cftr und ist das
einfach ist kombiniert aber ich wusste
schon ist leider falsch was ja ich war
da nicht mal ist gesorgt
dann nehme ich eine kurzvorstellung wird
das von sturms aber den körper nämlich
dann musst du uns einen original niemand
herr mit nur weil ich jetzt sprechen die
ich machen namen in deutschland recht
gibt es ist krieg es läuft aber
ausführlich lesen
[Musik]
das ist krisenniveau
es ist krieg so viel respiro das auch
kein bsp wir gehen es nicht das heißt du
diese zuckerstangen die man weiter
das ist ein buchstabe okay weil text du
hast gerade weil zu verlieren macht
weiter wie kommst du da bitte auf dem
bild mit wunsch als nächstes ist es
richtig wie kommst du darauf weil sie
ihm geraten war halt einfach nochmal
machen
2 ich merke doch keiner stimmt leute die
schon kunstwerke oder einen fehler macht
noch mag das dritte war ist das war ein
echter amerikanischer youtube
nein eigentlich das gegenteil das ist
das gegenteil von amerikaner hat man n
rein und damit hängt gut am gas noch mal
einen buchstaben noch dazu mache jetzt
mal ehrlich gesagt er erwarte ich gehe
der buchstabe für buchstabe heidi klum
er wollte für mich okay du bist du für
dich habe ich mir jetzt echt was kommt
die zins überlegt das kannst du drei jo
ok das ist eigentlich voll dumm dass ich
dazu sagen das wort genommen aber
eigentlich jeder buchstabe drittens ist
einfach das alphabet dem wunsch
assistieren
okay dann sag ich nein aber es klingt
doch schon ganz gut
es ist mal wieder wie dank ihres mega
viele aber die folgende theorie weiter
mit dem konto oh oh oh was holen
scorpions erc ja ok das liegt für süßen
babys in druck hier vor weil war auch
okay so warte ich mal aufgestellt
kurz bleiben in meiner vorstellung
technoclubs okay dann sag ich h
okay das ist dan roodt johanna ist nicht
drin ist nicht drin
[Musik]
du bist ganz schnell mal rasieren gerade
heiß sowie pokemon die weiterentwicklung
stehen tokios die kleinste fraktion ist
schon junge das recht gut hey ich hab so
viele buchstaben null plan was soll das
sein alter ego alter neu von mir und ich
habe 50 prozent von dem wort keinen
klaren okay
nein ja das ist richtig
3 ja ja nein das ist natürlich age 3
klatsche crispy leider war ich wie
productions dazu zwei buchstaben
falscher ist ja echt nicht gedacht schon
egal wen ich immer kleiner werden dann
mal los
a-tec respiro kann es nicht sein
natürlich hätte ich sagen soll ich das
sagen wie es geht so krass piraten immer
kostenlos sagen ob sie die videos
nein das ist kein heiliger
du hast auf gar keinen fall was es ist
halt dein maul ja das kann eine partie
gar keine ahnung wie keck dass er
eigentlich wie gehst du nach oben
nachdem nasen kommt heute aus dem wasser
ja was könnte es sein
[Musik]
so kann ich besser denken und letztes
genießen kann wenn man sich komplett in
klopapier also da ich jetzt kommen nicht
eingepackt bin würde ich sagen die bbg
großes b gesagt das ist schon selbst war
ich sag jetzt ein damit der kranken auf
das steht was doch ich würde sagen als
nächstes sebastian kommt er ein
buchstabe mit dem jetzt nicht rechnen
ist es nicht wahrscheinlich sagen werde
[Musik]
immer gleichen linie wie man hört man
was man das ende ist man p&c kräften
kräftig der kräfte richtig glaube ich
jetzt 11 werde da vorher was wär es
gewesen berichtet eine kraft hat nicht
nur touristen schon ganz ganz schön
kleiner china etwas wiedergeben
therapeutikum krieg sogar richtig es
nein warum steht laut e.on nö das noch
zwei fehler zu begehen das ein bisschen
an ran zahlen sage ich mal sagen ich hab
eine zahl drin ist das ist ja wohl ein
[Musik]
buch soll hier wieder keine ahnung was
das sein soll
m
[Musik]
naja wie wär's mit zwei php
ich geb dir tipi kopfnoten letzte
buchstabe jetzt verraten
damit steht jetzt 2 2 einstiger die
leute dann trage ich mich hier mal ein
wunderschönes da mit zwei zu eins wissen
leider ein bisschen hängengeblieben und
haben nicht herausfinden können wie
viele runden gespielt hat er angefangen
hat so was habe viel gedächtnis halbe
stunde her alles vergessen deswegen
können wir kommen